-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show", everybody.
It's time to play "Password."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, our first team tonight --
he plays Jughead on "Riverdale,"
and he's the host of
"The Tonight Show."
It's Cole Sprouse
and Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And their opponents are the
stars of "Grace and Frankie."
It's Lily Tomlin and Jane Fonda!
-Oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
-Now, the rules of the game
are very simple.
I will give each of you
a password.
-Uh-huh.
-Then you're gonna give
your one-word clue
to get your partner
to guess the password.
-Gotcha.
-The team with the most points
after four words --
-Wins the game.
-Yes.
-Wow.
-Any questions?
-Well --
-All right, great.
First clue...
[ Laughter ]
...goes to Cole and Jane.
-All right, here you go.
-The password is "squeak."
[ Laughter ]
-Jane, you can look at
the password.
-Cole, why don't
you start us out?
-All right,
we can do this buddy.
-All right, so --
I can do a gesture, too?
-No.
-Just one word.
-Aren't you on my team?
[ Laughter ]
-I want to win --
I want to win legit.
-Aren't you supposed to be
helping me out here?
-I want to be legit.
-Okay, okay. All right.
-You give me one word
and I got it.
I can feel the vibe
already, man.
-Mouse.
-Oh, that's what
I was gonna say.
[ Laughter ]
-It's one word --
is the password.
Mouse.
[ Laughter ]
-Squeak.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Yeah! Yes! Whoo!
-All right, the next clue
goes to Jimmy and Lily.
Now you got a different word.
-Me and you.
-The password is "yuck."
[ Light laughter ]
-Lily, you're up first.
-I'm trying to --
-Don't pay any attention to
my bandages.
Just focus on, you know,
what you're trying to do.
-Well, I don't know
if I can do that.
-It's hard for you to focus.
-I'm kind of --
I'm kind of obsessed with
looking at that bandage.
[ Laughter ]
-You've got to
move past it, Lily.
-Okay.
-Get to the game.
We can do this.
[ Light laughter ]
-Team.
-No, does it --
[ Laughter ]
-No, that wasn't the guess.
That wasn't the --
It's a one-word --
-She'll give a one-word clue.
-But that would have been
the right answer, yes.
One word, one word.
-Team?
-What, you said we could this,
so I thought --
-Okay, wait.
Okay, here's the thing.
Can I -- Can I say
"it sounds like"?
-No. No.
-No.
Don't say anything that rhymes
with this word. No.
[ Laughter ]
-Please don't -- In fact, on
television, you can't say --
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I gotcha.
-Oh.
-Ick!
[ Laughter ]
-That was
a full-body experience.
-I know. That was amazing.
She's a good actor.
-I thought you said
I can't do that.
-I know, but she just did it.
I don't know.
-I should have done that
to camera.
-[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-You can't say --
What is going on?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
A quarter in the jar.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
That was inco--
That was incorrect.
-Am I shocked.
[ Laughter ]
-Ick.
-You said the word!
-Wow, same clue.
-I said what you said,
kind of.
[ Laughter ]
You said, "Iiick."
And I said "Ick."
-Oh, you're saying the word!
[ Laughter ]
-Lily, that's a hint and you're
giving the wrong hint!
I'm not saying the word.
I'm saying --
[ Laughter ]
-You lose a point.
-Yeah, I lost a point.
-You lost a point.
-The word is -- the word --
-I'm carrying this team
right now.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-It was "Yuck."
-You don't say!
[ Laughter ]
-I think Cole knew it.
Cole knew it
and he's being sarcastic.
Cole.
-Okay.
-Jane, next clue's for you.
-Oh, my gosh.
-The password is "lollipop."
-Okay, Jane, why don't you
start us -- start off.
-Okay.
-This is good.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God!
This is a family show!
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you -- You've given me --
-Candy on a stick!
-You've given me
so many choices.
-Did you hear what I said?
She has a hard of hearing.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't.
-Candy.
Candy, the clue is, she said,
is candy.
-And the clue is candy.
-Candy.
[ Laughter ]
-Jane?
-Push-Up?
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
No, I couldn't -- I couldn't
guess anything.
Do I need to say anything here?
-I thought I'd try something.
-Yes, you do.
-Yeah, I think we got this,
right?
-Oh, no!
-Yeah, they do.
-Well, they just --
she said candy.
All right, and now,
what do you say?
-Cane.
[ Laughter ]
-It's my turn now!
We've already had
this erotic experience.
It's my turn.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you going to say cane? No.
-I wish.
-Unh-unh.
-Okay. All right, here you go.
Your one-word clue is...?
-Sucker.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Lollipop.
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Okay. Wow.
That's an all-day one.
-I thought that he was guessing
it instead --
-Here's the thing.
How does "lollipop" go with
sticking your finger --
[ Laughter ]
-It depends on what neighborhood
you're in.
Lily, Jimmy.
-The password is "sting."
-Okay, this is our final clue.
Jimmy, why don't you start us
off? Clean.
[ Laughter ]
-Bzzt!
Bzzzt!
[ Laughter ]
-You're looking
rather bee-wildered.
Bee?
-No. No.
-Lily, you give now your clue,
same word.
-Look at me.
[ Laughter ]
-No, look at me!
The game is much harder
when you look at me.
I like it that way.
[ Laughter ]
-Ouch!
-Mosquito.
-No!
-This is fantastic.
All right.
I feel like we've got this.
Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay, you have bzzt.
You got ouch.
-Sting.
-Yes!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-So funny.
-So sorry.
-Unbelievable.
-The winners right there are
me and Cole Sprouse!
We're talking to Lily Tomlin
and Jane Fonda.